Well, that's also something where, uh, you know, before,
when I've been on the show, we were talking about, uh,
the heart of everything that is about red cloud in the,
in the Western SU is the name of the book.
Maybe the book is the heart of everything that is, I wasn't getting super meta
the heart of everything. That is, is a great book about this, uh,
Sue from the Lakota nation, his chief red cloud,
and something that I love about those books is that they're like, Hey, listen,
native Americans did up. Right? Like they would gang rape.
It would smash babies into rocks and. But it's like,
cause everybody was a piece of at that time. Yes, everybody was,
everyone was doing up. And he didn't like even the.
Where you're like, well, what are the farms? They're cheap.
They're gonna win something.
You know, something where you're like, this is crazy. You're.
Doing it. It's like,
you can't deny like things like slavery and beating your wife and all that.
All these things are bad things. But guess what?
African-American Africans were selling other Africans into slavery. It's just,
it's either somebody else does it. Or you do it to your own.
That's just how the human brain works. And like Gandhi had 12 year old wife.
Yeah. I'm trying to tell you when anyone, when anyone tries to tell me, like,
if I was all like, yo, I loved sincerely Louis C K. Like,
I love that new special. And people are like, you watch that. I'm like, yeah.
Do you listen to the Beatles? Cool. John Lennon beat the out of his wife. Yeah.
Like, are we going to play this game? Yeah.
I don't believe in domestic violence. I think Louie did a up thing,
but I think you're worse. You're supporting a monster, a monster, but it's like,
you're going to, you're going to be able to.
Can cancel everybody, dude. It's like, what do you want me to tell you at that?
That's why I'm like, I go by the person I'm caring about the race, religion,
creed. It's like people make mistakes. Not everybody's all.
If anybody's appears to be a hundred percent perfect, stay.
Away from them, man. Do not.
Go near the people who appear to be perfect because they're sinister.
One of the biggest life lessons you can have is never,
never trust a man that doesn't have a shadow. I never trust someone.
That's not like I did this up. Because then you're like, what are you?
And then you find out that they have children, bones buried in their backyard,
dude, because it's like even Elvis was a pedophile Elvis Merrill,
Elvis married Priscilla when he was 24 and she was 14.
Wow. Look that up. That is, that is on record.
So I'd love to see all these people that are like,
I got to Graceland every year and you're like, cool. He was.
Kids in that house. You know,
they wouldn't call it Epstein land in your own.
Whoa. It's just like, he also stole black music.
The guy took black music and everyone's like, this is how you do it.
I know dude, people.
There it is. There's him with his child bride. Oh,
you ever have a Wolf? That's the fruit of the dork or hole.
Well, come on buddy. Here's the juice box. Come on Priscilla. Was she 14?
Or am I wrong? What she was? So that just outlook 14, you know,
they grew them different back then. I loved it because you.
Were dying in war when you were 17. Yeah. So it's like,
but that's the thing like times just change and now times are changing so quick
and we have to adapt to things so quick.
That's something you did last week was legal. And now you do it. It's like,
if you, you could get canceled, you can lose your whole career.
Your freedom because of it. It's scary.
I've said this before, but just to wrap up like the whole canceling thing,
especially being a comedian that we are like,
we're just trying to be funny all the time.
And we're not necessarily thinking about how this could look retroactively,
but I think, um, you gotta look at it as a comedian.
It's like we're smokers and you might get cancer. Cancer's getting canceled.
It's like, sometimes you can find it. Sometimes it kills you, you know?
But it's like, we're out here ripping buts. And it's like, yeah.
One of us, we're all we all my catcher who knows my aunt.
Colleen's listening to his episode. Like I liked that dance. God, really?
This guy gets it, honey. Get me another new pilot.
Thank you so much for watching. Hope you enjoyed the last video.
Don't forget to tell your friends, like subscribe and turn on notifications.
[Inaudible].